so this is a new idea kind of you
remember how we started this morning and
throughout this course we could say you
can take an awl idea and if you express
it in a new way sometimes you gain
insight or you can work with the problem
in a more effective way that's kind of
what this is okay so to explain what
this is the easiest way is to think back
to what we've just the outside okay so
you remember I said look I am the center
of the universe and I asked you all to
be a certain distance all the way around
me why I was there I was at the center
of a set of points for set of points and
you traced our circle right you trace
out a circle this isn't very important
involved it but because this is the
definition all circle right a circle is
a circle is what you are doing around me
right that's what defines a circle a
circle is in our case right a set of
points set of points that are
equidistant from one central point and
this was helpful because you're all
literally standing around me and you
were different points and there was a
set of you right they were all 24:23 of
you to them okay that are equidistant
from one central point okay now I'm
going to take this definition right
which is a geometric definition and I'm
going to just slightly turn a little bit
same over these must-attend words but I
want to turn it just a little bit so we
can employ some of the other language
and notation and tools that were editor
to talk about circles okay so instead of
saying it's a set of points right as in
there's a whole bunch of them right and
they're all doing the same thing okay
instead I want to say a circle is
while the set points 1 2 3 4 5 etc or we
are to infinity I want to say it's a
part a circle is the path that's traced
out by rather than a set of points one
point that moves ok I'll say that again
we write it down ok a circle is the path
traced out by one point that moves
according to the same idea down here
that we said before namely being
equidistant from one certain place a
circle is the part traced out by one
point that move such that it's always
the same distance it's always
equidistant from a central point
or you could say remains a on a constant
distance because it's not changing right
it's a bit adventure you use the word
equidistant here because there's only
one point and you can't compare you
can't say one thing is equidistant to
itself you need two things to be easy
right bless you remains a safe distance
from the central point
all right so can you see we have just
very very subtly turned this idea of a
set of points a whole bunch of them
right to one point that moves it's a
geometric definition of the circle now
we're going to take this idea and we're
going to apply all that we know about
coordinate geometry to take this
language and express it symbolically
okay so here's his arm what we're going
to do here let's actually situate this
in space okay what would you estimate
was the distance between Cassini right
now first time - Naboo
like three three meters four meters
let's go through okay so here we go
example okay because because we're
establishing that I'm the center of the
universe okay we're going to say there's
a point a point right but it can move
right so it's coordinates can change
right now we used to say it okay you
know you've got some point and it's got
coordinates here or you've got some
point and it's got coordinates here okay
now if it's coordinates can change we
can't just put a number on those
coordinates they have to be something
variable right so therefore I'm going to
say there is a point P and I'm going to
name its x coordinates and Y coordinates
x and y because they indicate they can
change X comma Y right so it's a point
but it's moving through space that's why
it's coordinates are variables okay as
point P that moves so it is always what
do we say something like three three
units from the origin
okay now the question that will then
come is what is and here's the word what
is the likeness of this point what's the
path that gets traced out by this point
as it moves okay now we already know
what the answer is but let's show how
that is arrived at okay so the question
is what is the locus of this point which
means you know what's the part that
traces out what's the equation that
defines all those points so carpets from
the origin rights from the origin what
we usually conventionally call the
origin we tend to its coordinates 0 0 we
tend to call it home for origin so that
means that the distance from P to O is 3
units do you grow that that's that's
kind of what this is saying
but in symbolic form right P equals 3
that's what it is by definition but I
know how to find the distance between
two points don't I and this is one of
the points and the other point is this
right I just use the distance formula
right what does the distance formula
tell me in Farm these are my two points
quite it for me PR is equal to the
square root of what's going to go on to
the Swagger's in your square okay good
you take the two x coordinate plus y
minus y minus 0 squared so where does
this come from it comes from Pythagoras
all right and that's equal to 3 do you
agree with that like that's the distance
and it's always equal to 3 units okay
there's not much to this right assuming
there aren't two people in your way okay
um X minus zero squared is just X square
why - 0 all squared is just Y squared
and then to neaten things out I'm just
going to square both sides ok these
things are both positive this is
positive this is positive so I'm not
going to add anything on to this just by
saying that is equal to 9 okay and this
of course you already knew we've met
before
the equation of a circle with center at
the origin right that's the center and a
radius of radius that's what this thing
really is all that's 3 squared isn't it
as you seen this before but you see this
way of approaching it or saying there's
a geometric rule that underlies this
that's where the equation comes from